El miedo a quedarse sin petróleo fue durante
décadas uno de los pronósticos más recurrentes
y al mismo tiempo que más titulares, alarma
y controversia generaba. Incluso era motivo
de estudio o, al menos, advertencia hasta
en las propias escuelas. ¿Os acordáis?
Quizás lo fuera en buena medida porque la
disponibilidad de fuentes de energía aprovechables
era mucho más limitada de lo que es hoy en
día.
Y de hecho, tanto es así que, como los malos
augurios nunca se cumplían, las profecías
se fueron retrasando una y otra y otra vez.
¡Algún día tendría que llegar el tan ansiado
fin del petróleo!
(“El mundo se va a quedar sin petróleo
en 10 años.” - Oficina de Minas de Estados
Unidos, en 1914)
(“El mundo se va a quedar sin petróleo
en 13 años.” - Oficina de Minas de Estados
Unidos, en 1939 y 1950)
(“El mundo se va a quedar sin petróleo
y otros combustibles fósiles en 1990.”
- Paul Erlich, Los Límites del Crecimiento,
en 1973)
(“El mundo se va a quedar sin petróleo
en 2030, y sin combustibles fósiles en 2050.”
- Paul Erlich, Más allá del Límite, en
2002)
Como veis no dieron ni una. Por supuesto,
lo que toda esta gente no tuvo nunca en cuenta
fue la evolución tecnológica que el ser
humano iba a seguir alimentando con el paso
de los años.
Y no solo hablamos del petróleo. El miedo
a quedarse sin una fuente de energía abundante
fue una constante entre periodistas, analistas
y expertos de todo tipo.
De hecho, hoy cuando hablamos de los combustibles
fósiles lo que más nos suele importar es
la contaminación, pero lo cierto es que durante
años no fue una cuestión de conciencia ambiental
sino de miedo, miedo a quedarnos sin suministros.
En cualquier caso, la cuestión es que estamos
en pleno siglo XXI y salvo por la energía
nuclear todo el mundo parece correr hacia
un futuro sin energías fósiles. ¿Todo el
mundo? ¡No! Al mejor estilo de la aldea de
Asterix un país poblado por irreductibles
samuráis resiste contra viento y marea.
Queridos amigos, amigas, durante los últimos
años Japón ha ido en contra de la tendencia
global. Y no solo no ha reducido su consumo
de combustibles fósiles, sino que lo ha incrementado.
(2011 fue para Japón una especie de punto
y aparte. El terremoto y el posterior tsunami
con sus devastadores efectos sobre la central
nuclear de Fukushima cambiaron el planteamiento
energético del país. Si hasta ese momento
los japoneses abrazaban la energía luego
ya la cosa fue diferente. Querían buscar
alternativas.
El incidente de Fukushima se saldó con muchos
de los reactores nucleares del país detenidos,
situación que se prolonga hasta el día de
hoy. Evidentemente toda esa energía tuvo
que ser suplida de alguna manera.
Sí, con renovables pero también inicialmente
con petróleo y gas, muchísimo gas.)
Tanto fue así que en 2016 las fuentes de
energía primaria procedentes de combustibles
fósiles llegaron a suponer más del 90% de
todo el consumo nacional,
Lo que en un país con tan poco recursos naturales
aprovechables como Japón supuso tener que
cubrir con importaciones más del 80% de todas
sus necesidades energéticas. Japón es uno
de los países energéticamente más dependientes
del mundo.
El caso es que eso hizo saltar todas las alarmas
en Tokyo. Y no es que se tratara de una cuestión
medioambiental, sino también y sobre todo
estratégica, económica y geopolítica.
Y es que, para un país cómo Japón depender
íntegramente del suministro de combustibles
fósiles de origen extrajero y traídos por
barco supone un enorme riesgo para la seguridad
nacional. Especialmente en un momento en el
que Xi Jinping ha puesto patas arriba la geopolítica
en esta región del mundo.
Amigos, amigas, durante años los políticos
japoneses apostaron por la energía nuclear
como la mejor fórmula para ganar autonomía.
Pero, ¿qué ocurre si ya no quieres o electoralmente
no puedes contar con ella? Digamos que hoy
por hoy no es la fuente de energía más popular
en Japón.
Y precisamente por eso se lanzaron en masa
a desarrollar las energías renovables como
si no hubiera mañana, especialmente la energía
solar. Pero claro, sustituir la energía nuclear
son palabras mayores.
Así que la pregunta, la gran pregunta que
podemos hacernos es, ¿Cuál es la solución
que los japoneses han puesto sobre la mesa?
¿En qué han pensado exactamente? ¿Tienen
alguna idea original?
Pues, aunque pueda sorprenderte una de las
hipótesis, una de las soluciones que manejan
a todo este embrollo pasa por convertirse
en algo así como los nuevos jeques del gas.
Convertirse en grandes productores a toda
costa. Pero hay un problema: No tienen gas.
No al menos, lo que todos conocemos como el
gas natural convencional.
Y justo aquí, en este preciso instante ha
llegado la hora de poner sobre la mesa la
que puede convertirse en una de las grandes
apuestas estratégicas de Japón: el hidrato
de metano.
¿Alguna vez habéis escuchado hablar de este
compuesto? Me da que la mayoría no, ¿me
equivoco?
Pues… prestad atención porque os vamos
a contar en qué consiste, cómo se puede
aprovechar y qué demonios están pensando
en Japón.
Atentos.
(EL HIELO INFLAMABLE)
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. No nos hemos
vuelto locos. Existe un “hielo” que si
lo quemas, prende.
Se llama hidrato de metano y lo hay en cantidades
enormes a lo largo y ancho de todo el planeta.
Concretamente debajo del lecho oceánico.
Y, ojo, porque esto último es lo que lo convierte
en una de las materias primas más deseadas,
pero al mismo tiempo también más controvertidas.
Al fin y al cabo, en el lecho oceánico no
solo existen ecosistemas tan únicos como
frágiles sino que además extraer materias
primas de él es una operación que conlleva
muchos riesgos.
Pero para entender la importancia que tiene
este recurso tenemos que aparcar aunque sea
por un momento las consideraciones ambientales
y centrarnos en su enorme potencial, que la
verdad, creo puede sorprenderos.
(El hidrato de metano es la fuente de carbono
más abundante de la Tierra. Se estima que
aglutina un tercio de todo el carbono del
planeta. Y, ojo, porque las estimaciones en
torno a las reservas globales de Hidrato de
Metano del Departamento de Energía de los
Estados Unidos apuntan a que su poder energético
podría superar al de todos los demás combustibles
fósiles conocidos.
Quizás por ello, China está realizando pruebas
de extracción de este recurso en el Mar de
China Meridional. Y de hecho es algo que Pekín
podría estar teniendo en cuenta a la hora
de extender sus reclamaciones marítimas.
Sin embargo, hablamos de un compuesto que
es altamente inestable, muy inflamable y particularmente
sensible a la presión y a la temperatura.
Características que hacen que su extracción
no sea ni mucho menos sea algo tan sencillo
como emplear la minería tradicional, es decir,
excavar, recogerlo y transportarlo a tierra
firme.)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué hablamos de Japón
y no de otros países cuando nos referimos
a este hielo inflamable?
Pues echad un vistazo atentamente a este mapa
para poder entenderlo. Cada uno de los puntos
verdes hacen referencia a depósitos conocidos
de hidrato de metano en el mundo.
Tal y como podéis ver la mayor concentración
conocida de esta materia prima se sitúa precisamente
entorno a Japón.
La costa nipona está literalmente salpicada
por depósitos de este compuesto. Lo que en
gran medida se debe a la confluencia de placas
tectónicas y a los enormes depósitos sedimentarios
que hay frente a su costa.
¡No todo iba a ser malo! ¡Algo bueno tenía
que tener ser una de las zonas con más riesgo
sísmico del planeta! ¿No os parece?
Pues, ya lo veis, en este caso la compensación
es que Japón es uno de los países con mayores
reservas de hidrato de metano de todo el planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el gobierno
japonés calcula que en su territorio hay
por lo menos 7 billones de metros cúbicos
de hidrato de metano en depósitos offshore.
Eso podría llegar a ser suficiente como para
satisfacer todo el consumo de gas de Japón
durante casi un siglo. E, insisto, podría
haber mucho más hidrato.
Precisamente por eso hay pocas dudas acerca
de que la extracción de hidrato de metano
podría garantizar el suministro energético
por mucho, muchísimo tiempo. Evidentemente
no solo en Japón.
Pero… Un momento, porque no resulta tan
sencillo. El problema es que todavía no se
sabe muy bien cómo aprovecharlo, especialmente
cómo extraerlo y procesarlo.
Pues bien, hoy por hoy para hacerlo hay dos
formas. Una, llamémoslo convencional, y otra
digamos un poquito más revolucionaria, que
es la que Japón está intentando desarrollar.
(La manera tradicional consiste en extraer
este recurso mediante perforaciones del lecho
marino en profundidades de unos 1.000 metros.
Además hay que tener en cuenta que los depósitos
no se encuentran en el agua, sino que se sitúan
a unos cuantos cientos de metros por debajo
del lecho marino, lo que implica una complejidad
adicional y unos costes tan elevados que,
a día de hoy, no permiten que esta opción
sea comercialmente viable.
Y luego está la forma más revolucionaria,
que es en la que está trabajando Japón.
Empresas como Modec o Mitsubishi Shipbuilding
están desarrollando barcos extractores que
sean capaces de extraer de forma segura los
depósitos de hidrato de metano más cercanos
a la costa.
Esto se haría “pinchando” el lecho marino
hasta llegar al depósito, y dejar que el
hidrato de metano ascienda al barco extractor,
que a su vez podría apoyarse en otros barcos
auxiliares para transportarlo a la costa o
incluso almacenarlo y transformarlo en gas
metano in situ.)
Parece simple, ¿verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que no lo es en absoluto.
La complejidad técnica viene sobre todo,
como ya comentamos antes, por la inestabilidad
de este recurso y también por el riesgo de
contaminación, ya que de no hacerlo bien
podrían ser liberadas altas cantidades de
metano al mar y, luego, a la atmósfera.
Y claro, esto no es bueno ni lejos ni cerca
de la costa, pero cerca es todavía peor.
Además, más allá de los riesgos, la extracción
en sí misma resulta complicada incluso técnicamente.
Digamos que durante el proceso de perforación
se corre el riesgo de que entre arena o cualquier
otra cosa al depósito a través de la perforación,
y eso podría desestabilizar el hidrato de
metano hasta el punto de volverlo inutilizable.
Pero en fin, es en lo que están trabajando.
El objetivo es conseguir gas, gas y más gas,
y que sea lo más barato posible para los
nipones.
Pero, ojo, porque nos falta un detalle clave:
lo que Japón aspira es a convertirse en toda
una potencia productora de hidrógeno, produciéndolo,
precisamente, con el gas extraído de los
depósitos de hidrato de metano. Un “yo
me lo guiso, yo me lo como” en toda regla.
Y tal y como ya os contamos en un vídeo que
publicamos hace poco tiempo sobre el hidrógeno
- el cual por cierto, os dejo aquí abajo
en la descripción - las implicaciones podrían
ser enormes.
Pero, un momento, si estamos hablando de hidrato
de metano, ¿qué demonios pinta aquí el
hidrógeno?
Atentos.
(¿EL TRAMPOLÍN NIPÓN HACIA EL HIDRÓGENO?)
Amigos, tal y como os contamos en el vídeo
del hidrógeno, este combustible se puede
producir de varias mareas distintas. La más
frecuentes es producirlo utilizando carbón,
gas natural o más recientemente también
energías renovables.
Pues bien, he aquí la clave de las intenciones
energéticas de Japón: extraer hidrato de
metano y utilizarlo para producir hidrógeno.
Para que os hagáis una idea, un metro cúbico
de hidrato de metano puede producir aproximadamente
160 metros cúbicos de gas metano, que después
se pueden transformar asimismo en hidrógeno.
De esta forma, países con amplios depósitos
de hidrato de metano tal y como es el caso
de Japón podrían transitar muy rápidamente
hacia el hidrógeno y utilizarlo como combustible
limpio y no dependiente de las importaciones.
(De hecho, el hidrógeno es un pilar cada
vez más importante en la estrategia energética
del gobierno de japón, el cual espera estimular
el consumo de este combustible por encima
de las 20 millones de toneladas para el 2050.
Un objetivo relativamente elevado, especialmente
si tenemos en cuenta que por unidad de peso
la potencia energética del hidrógeno es
tres veces la de la gasolina, pero que solo
será posible alcanzar si se logran reducir
sustancialmente sus costes de producción.
De esta forma, el plan del gobierno nipón
pasa por reducir de 100 a 20 yenes por metro
cúbico el coste de producción del hidrógeno.
Esto es, de 91 a 18 centavos de dólar. Y
para lograr ese objetivo, entre otras cosas,
el país necesita un suministro de energía
muy competitivo. Potencialmente el hidrato
de metano.
Y no solo eso, además producir hidrógeno
con el gas derivado del hidrato de metano
sería más limpio que hacerlo con otras fuentes,
ya que el hidrato de metano emite un 30% menos
de dióxido de carbono cuando se quema que
el carbón o el petróleo.)
La cuestión es, ¿será posible aprovechar
el hidrato de metano a escala comercial, y
que sea económicamente viable? Y luego otra
pregunta que hay que hacerse es… ¿podrá
el hidrógeno acelerar su despegue gracias
al hidrato de metano?
(Japón se fija en el “hielo inflamable”
submarino como fuente de hidrógeno de combustión
limpia - Nikkei Asia)
Pues, amigos, esta es la revolución energética
a la que está tratando de subirse Japón.
Una técnica que luego se complementaría
con las tecnologías de captura de carbono.
Y es que de esta forma Japón podría lograr
una enorme autonomía energética.
Ahora bien, ¿será algún día viable? No
está claro, pero por lo pronto, en 2017,
el país del sol naciente consiguió a través
de su proyecto experimental en la fosa de
Nankai extraer hidrato de metano durante 24
días sin ninguna incidencia técnica.
Y no solo eso, el Gobierno cree que conseguirá
arrancar proyectos comerciales con hidrato
de metano entre los años 2023 y 2027. O al
menos eso es lo que dice su último Plan Estratégico
de Energía.
Por lo pronto, llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti. ¿Crees que deberíamos aprovechar
a escala masiva el gas que está “dormido”
en los depósitos de hidrato de metano? ¿O
crees que bajo ningún concepto se deberían
realizar extracciones de este tipo por los
riesgos ambientales que conlleva?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
este vídeo no olvides darle like y suscribirte
a Visualpolitik.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo
y hasta la próxima.